[Musique]
souvenez vous de vos 20 ans si par
chance vous saviez déjà ce que vous
vouliez faire imaginer une crise
sanitaire chamboulé vos plans refroidir
les employeurs et voire des centaines de
concurrents expérimentés viser le même
poste que vous voici la réalité des
jeunes actifs que nous avons rencontrés
coincé entre les jobs alimentaires et
les retours négatifs entre le doute et
la résilience
ils sont à la recherche de leur premier
emploi ils ont trouvé les premières
galères oui ok je m'appelle laura
szymanski j'ai 20 ans je travaille donc
un but entrecôte est qu'est ce c'est
d'accueil depuis donc fin novembre 2020
thème de cuisson ouais ok alors nous on
l'a bien en stock que vous venez quand
vous avez un moment dans tous les cas
c'est un mac alors à es et puis après je
me suis engagé vers un bts tourisme donc
pendant deux ans en alternance et donc
qui s'est terminée en juillet 2020 et à
la suite de ça donc
je trouvais f1 j'ai cherché un emploi
donc je suis dirigé ici avec la crise du
coc vite qu'ils étaient compliquées
c'est une réalité qui n'est pas décrite
sur les brochures de bts s'il aura
accueilli les clients répondent au
téléphone et garde son sourire face aux
demandes
elle s'imaginait le faire dans un autre
contexte je m'occupe un petit peu de
l'administratif je regarde ce qui a été
fait la veille les bons d'achat les
emprises les remboursements les
encaissements je regarde les bons de
sortie de la veille les suivi de
livraison ce que je voulais vraiment
c'était travers l'écotourisme au départ
donc on en est vraiment très très loin
mais au moins être resté dans l'univers
de tourisme proposer des prestations
touristiques des activités être dans un
milieu du tourisme
pas forcément dans le mythe de la même
le mans mais ça reste une bonne
expérience une expérience qui se
prolonge
laura travail dans ce magasin spécialisé
depuis novembre 2020
face à la fermeture des lieux
touristiques et des agences de voyages
elle a fini par se résoudre et prendre
un job alimentaire comme premier emploi
pas de remords lorsqu'il faut sortir de
la précarité
j'ai un cdi au fond avec but donc moi
j'ai commencé fin novembre et donc
j'irai jusqu'au bout jusque je pourrais
donc pour le moment vous n'avez pas de
vraiment date de sortie vous dit pendant
un an maximum je m'en vais sur deux
choses on verra mon but est comme de
décès de retourner de norma branche
après je suis jeune que je ça me fait de
l'expérience au moins je travaille j'ai
j'ai un salaire et puis c'est ce que je
vois c'est ça reste positif quand même
en période de confinement
la moyenne d'âge dans l'entrepôt ne
dépasse pas la vingtaine les jeunes sont
issus de formations diverses des
salariés parfois sur qualifiés qui sont
rapidement recruté grâce à un excellent
chiffre d'affaires en 2020
nous avons embauché plus cette année
pour revenir sur le contrat des jeunes
et des étudiants c'est 30 % d'effectifs
supplémentaires sur ce magasin cette
année
d'accord ce qui représente combien de
personnes alors sur le mois de décembre
c'était dix étudiants supplémentaires
par tous en cdi du cdd certains en cdi
certains en intérim fermeture des
boutiques confinement après 19 heures
laura prend l'air avec sa colocataire
qui partage avec elle les mêmes galères
je m'appelle chloé van mail art je suis
diplômé dans le tourisme et je travaille
dans un parc de loisirs ici juste à côté
dans le village à côté qui est pour
l'instant fermé depuis environ quatre
mois
maintenant oui tout à fait je suis un
chômage partiel avec des périodes
d'ouverture et de fermeture mais en gros
depuis un an lorsque laura évoque ses
ambitions dans le tourisme elle reste
prudente et encore des personnes qui
sont en étude allons sortir elles vont
vouloir forcément travailler comme nous
et bailly voir à cette place pour tous
c'est sûr je vais essayer de me donner
moyens d'y arriver après c'est qu'une
question de volonté
quand on veut vraiment mon trou mais ça
va être compliqué si certains acceptent
les jobs alimentaires d'autres jeunes
refusent de changer de voie
[Musique]
chaque matin le rituel est le même
ordinateur ouvert échanges de mails
prospection enola semble être en
télétravail mais elle cherche en réalité
son premier emploi l'été dernier elle a
été diplômée à 25 ans d'un master en
marketing et communication
un secteur en pleine crise donc là par
exemple on a un poste de chargée de
communication
donc on peut voir justice est en dessous
ça permet d'avoir un ordre d'idée quand
on postule que ici il ya eu plus de 100
candidatures mais ça permet de mesurer
un petit peu on se place et de se dire
bon va falloir faire la différence qu au
milieu sans candidat sur ça fait
beaucoup de monde ces derniers mois
enola à candidater à plusieurs dizaines
d'annonce la plupart du temps elle ne
reçoit aucun retour des employeurs
malgré son bac + 5
elle a dû revoir ses ambitions à la
baisse quand on fait les études on
s'attend pas à commencer avec le smic
alors qu'on a un bac + 5
c'est vrai que ça j'ai dû revoir je
m'attendais vraiment pas à ça même avec
ma conseillère pôle emploi quand on
rencontre au premier rendez-vous sont
conseillés ont fait une fiche de poste
donc le poste idéal
j'avais émis donc en salaire pour pour
débuter donc avec un au bac + 5 je
trouvais que c'était correct par rapport
à ce que j'avais comparé aux offres qui
avait de disponible sur le marché
j'avais mis 1600 en salaire minimum je
trouvais rien on est blessé à 1004 et
ont trouvé rien non plus donc là j'ai
mis le smic et malheureusement on trouve
pas grand chose donc c'est un peu
compliqué face à cette situation
désespérée la jeune diplômée et en
recherche de conseils
elle s'est tournée vers une solution qui
prend de l'ampleur le mentorat beau
alors comment ça se passe depuis notre
dernière rencontre
concrètement un salarié d'une grande
entreprise se porte volontaire pour
prendre un jeune sous son aile et le
conseiller dans sa recherche d'emploi
aujourd'hui trente mille jeunes sont
concernés le gouvernement espère monter
à 100 milles d'ici la fin de l'année
pour enola cet échange est aussi
l'occasion d' éviter les pièges
trois heures et je vais expliquer donc
ma part quand on s'était vus on avait pu
1200 il m'a dit ah non 1200 c'était pure
une base de 35 heures donc je vais dire
aux mille euros nets c'est pas possible
c'est trop bas donc après je les sais
qu'en ce moment c'est une période
difficile aussi pour les commerçants
mais quand même c'est pas une
reconnaissance de vos compétences est ce
que vous savez faire
si vous où vous seriez prêteurs à non
majesté les choses
bon c'est pas comment lui expliquer sont
braqués quoi bon c'est ça non c'est de
mon point de vue un cercle en panne
quand vous êtes bac +5 pas vaincu 50 pas
au niveau du smic quoi enfin ces voix là
pour plus compliqué que ça
mon rôle tel que je n'imagine c'est à la
fois de sa d'être en écoute en
organisation on appuie donc on allait
changer qui nous l'assurent basse et ça
c'était quoi les offres qu'elle faisait
est ce qu'elle est à peu près bien
cibler ce qu'elle était suivie sans
emploi depuis sa sortie d'école elle est
passée d'un bac + 5 à bac + doute un
moment donné il se peut que vous dites
bon bah j'arrête et je passe à autre
chose est-ce que ce que ça peut
traverser votre esprit
alors oui je pense à a traversé mon
esprit à plusieurs reprises où je me
posais la question est-ce que c'est par
rapport à la crise que je trouve pas
travail ou est ce que parce que si tout
simplement que finalement j'ai pas les
compétences malgré mes diplômes et c'est
vrai que j'ai eu c'est petit coup de mou
là où je me posais la question après
heureusement qu'elle entourage qui qui
remonte un peu le moral et puis qui n'en
faut pas que tu abandonnes pour pas que
que tu laisses tomber tap avait fait
toutes ses études pour ça oublié sa
formation et accepter un job alimentaire
ou persister pour trouver l'emploi qui
correspond quitte à rester dans la
précarité
face à la crise sanitaire les
désillusions s'enchaînent
ce qu vida a renvoyé l'être humain a ses
valeurs profondes et sa remise en cause
les psychologues du travail les
consultants que nous sommes je suis à la
fois consultante mais également
psychologue du travail
prendre le temps de s'arrêter de faire
cette introspection et de se dire ok il
ya vos acquis les acquis ce sont les
diplômes c'est le parcours professionnel
mais visualiser effectivement quelque
chose de positif mais il faut surtout
pas rester isolé il ya énormément de
choses aujourd'hui qui existent pour
reprendre du lien social
autre que physique et on y reviendra de
toute façon à ce lien social mais ne pas
rester dans l'est dans l'isolément
surtout pas surtout pas c'est dur
d'avoir 20 en 2020
c'est dur donc je donnerais jamais de
leçon à nos jeunes parce que ce sont
ceux qui honnêtement vivent un sacrifice
terrible des examens annulé de l'
angoisse pour les formations de l'
angoisse pour trouver le premier job
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a mis une
telle mobilisation
un jeune une solution lancé en juillet
dernier un jeune une solution c'est 9
milliards d'euros pour aider les jeunes
à trouver un emploi
premiers bénéficiaires les entreprises
qui embauchent des alternants jusqu'au
31 décembre 2021
chaque apprenti peut rapporter jusqu'à
8000 euros d' aide à son entreprise
mais l'état ne s'arrête pas là crise
oblige les dispositifs dead sont
renforcés garantie jeunes auprès des
missions locales pour les déscolarisés
cordées de la réussite pour renforcer
l'égalité des chances ou encore la dgi
l'accompagnons intensif des jeunes chez
pôle emploi donc là ça fait à peu près
15 jours que vous êtes en poste
comment ça se passe alors
il ya eu la période d'adaptation
attendant donc au début mon jeu observé
surtout beaucoup donc j'ai essayé
d'apprendre
ça s'est fait naturellement dans la
région centre val de loire
plus de six mille demandeurs d'emploi en
2020 au bénéficier de la ji concrètement
ce sont des conseillers pôle emploi
entièrement dédié à ce jeune public
objectif affiché trouver un emploi en
six mois je vide à châtillon sur loire
donc voilà c'est un petit village ça
fait pas longtemps que j'y suis je suis
venue d'une très grande ville donc je
passe à une tout petit village
donc ça a été très difficile au tout
début donc je m'étais posé beaucoup de
questions si j'avais vraiment trouver un
emploi surtout dans le secteur que je
voulais vraiment à effectuer donc après
ma concert m'a beaucoup soutenu dans mon
projet elle m'a pas non plus orienté
vers quelque chose d'autre s avec eux
c'est ce que je voulais faire désormais
mariam et en cdd jusqu'au 31 décembre
dans les ressources humaines son secteur
de prédilection
destiné à un public de jeunes demandeurs
d'emploi jeunes demandeurs d'emploi tout
le temps voilà je ne fais que ça je fais
j'ai soixante dix jeunes ont suivi à peu
près en moyenne et du coup voilà je ne
fais que ça je ne fais pas d'accueil ou
d'autres d'autres d'autres activités qui
ont conseillé classique fait donc j'ai
mon temps pour pour les pour le
diagnostic pôle accompagnement pour la
promotion de profil pour aller en
entreprise voilà j'ai vraiment jeu
mon objectif c'est le retour à l'emploi
des jeunes d'après l'insee en 2020 plus
d'un million et demi de jeunes entre 15
et 29 ans sont soit au chômage ou bien
déscolarisés et sans aucune formation
dans les prochaines semaines le
gouvernement pourrait annoncer la mise
en place du rsa jeunes
une aide de 500 euros par mois pour les
moins de 25 ans qui sont dans cette
situation et qui cherchent un emploi
face au co vite le contrat de travail
c'est l'objectif numéro un
quoi qu'il en coûte
[Musique]